وفي ردود الفعل العربيه دانت وزاره
الخارجيه الاردنيه باشد العبارات اقدام
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي على اقتحام
المسجد الاقصى المبارك تحت حراسه وحمايه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وحملت الخارجيه
في بيان اسرائيل كامل المسؤوليه عن
التابعات الخطيره لاقتحام بن جرير للمسجد
الاقصى وقالت الخارجيه ان القيام احد
وزراء الحكومه الاسرائيليه باقتحام الاقصى
وانتهاك حرمته خطوه استفزازيه مدانه من
جهتها اعربت الخارجيه المصريه عن اساسها
الاقتحام مسؤولا اسرائيليا رسمي المسجد
الاقصى واكد رفضها لاي اجراءات احديه
مخالفه للقانون الدولي كما دانت الكويت
اقتحام من سمته الوزيره المتطرف في حكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باحات المسجد الاقصى
واعتبرته استفزادا لمشاعر المسلمين
وانتهاكا لقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ذات
قطر بشده اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي باحات المسجد الاقصى واعتبرته
انتهاكا سافرا للقانون الدولي محذره من
السياسه التصعيديه التي تتبناها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله
بدورها نددت الخارجيه السعوديه بما وصفتها
بالممارسات الاستفزازيه التي قام بها احد
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين باقتحام باحات
المسجد الاقصى الشريف